HEY, ALL I KNOW IS ITS GOOD
HAVING ANOTHER BROTHER
MOVE INTO THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
- HEY, MAN, IT'S GOOD
TO HAVE YOU OVER.
AND I THINK
THAT YOU WILL DIG THIS.
- ALL RIGHT.
HEY!
- HUH?
- NICE GUITAR COLLECTION.
- OH, THANKS, MAN.
HEY, YOU WANNA HEAR SOMETHING?
- YEAH, SURE.
- ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S GET THIS STARTED.
[playing guitar]
♪ WELL, I'M JUST
A GOOD OLD AMERICAN BOY ♪
♪ WITH A HEART
THAT'S RED, WHITE, AND TRUE ♪
♪ I'M DREAMIN' OF THE GIRL
WITH THE RED HAIR AND FRECKLES ♪
♪ AND HER EYES LIKE
THE SKIES OF BLUE ♪
- COUNTRY MUSIC.
- YEAH, I GREW UP IN TEXAS.
YOU KNOW, SO...
- ALL RIGHT.
- ♪ KEEP HER SAFE
FROM THE HOMIES ♪
♪ IN THE WRONG SIDE
OF TOWN ♪
♪ WHERE THEY'RE SMOKIN' THE
REEFER AND ACTING LIKE CLOWNS ♪
♪ KEEP THAT PRETTY WHITE DRESS
FROM GETTING DIRTY AND BROWN ♪
♪ 'CAUSE THAT'S
THE AMERICAN WAY ♪
WOO-HOO!
- WHOA.
PRETTY RACIST SONG.
[both laugh]
- RACIST?
AGAINST WHO?
- BLACK PEOPLE.
- BLACK PEOPLE?
BUT I'M BLACK.
[laughs]
- WELL, KEEPING
THE REDHEADED GIRL AWAY
FROM THE HOMIES
ON THE WRONG SIDE OF TOWN?
- HOMIES?
COME ON, BROTHER.
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF HOMIES.
YOU KNOW, WHITE HOMIES,
ASIAN HOMIES.
- NO, HOMIES ARE BLACK.
- NO, I THINK YOU'RE
MAKING THEM BLACK, MAN.
I THINK THAT'S YOUR STUFF.
YOU HEAR THE TWANG AND THEN
YOU ASSUME THAT IT'S RACIST.
BUT THAT'S JUST
WHAT COUNTRY MUSIC IS LIKE.
HERE, LOOK, YOU'RE
GONNA LIKE THIS ONE.
YOU'LL LIKE THIS ONE.
- ALL RIGHT.
- [playing guitar]
♪ SOME FOLKS WEAR THEIR HATS
WAY OFF TO THE SIDE ♪
♪ WITH THEIR PANTS DOWN LOW
AND A GUN TUCKED INSIDE ♪
♪ TAKE THEIR BEER BY THE 40
AND THEIR CHICKEN DEEP-FRIED ♪
♪ I THINK WE ALL KNOW
WHO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ♪
♪ THE ONLY DARK I LIKE
IS WHEN I TURN OFF THE LIGHTS ♪
♪ THE ONLY HOOD I LOVE
IS POINTY AND WHITE ♪
♪ CAN'T TRUST YOU
IF I CAN'T ♪
♪ SEE YOUR FACE
AT NIGHT ♪
♪ I THINK WE ALL KNOW
WHO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ♪
- ALL RIGHT, WAIT. HEY!
STOP THAT.
THAT'S RACIST.
- WHAT'S--WHAT?
WHAT IS RACIST ABOUT IT?
- "THE ONLY HOOD I LOVE
IS POINTY AND WHITE"?
- YEAH, MAN.
- THAT'S TALKING
ABOUT THE KLAN, MAN.
- THE KU KLUX KLAN?
ARE YOU OUTSIDE OF YOUR MIND?
THAT'S TRADITIONAL
COUNTRY MUSIC IMAGERY, MAN,
LIKE A PICKUP TRUCK
OR SLEEPING UNDER THE STARS,
OR YOUR DOG GOT KILLED
OR YOUR WIFE LEFT YOU.
SAME THING!
- I WOULD HAVE BEEN FINE
WITH ANY OF THOSE THINGS.
- WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THOSE THINGS
AND WHAT IS IN THE SONG?
- THEY'RE NOT RACIAL!
- HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
CAN I JUST SAY SOMETHING, MAN?
I'M JUST GONNA BE FRANK.
YOU'RE GETTING A LITTLE,
LIKE, AL SHARPTON,
LIKE, FARRAKHAN
ON ME RIGHT NOW.
- OH, MY GOD.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
- YO, DUDE, DUDE, PLEASE.
HEY, CAN I DO ONE MORE?
LET ME JUST
DO ONE MORE, DOG.
I ABSOLUTELY PROMISE YOU
THAT THIS SONG IS NOT RACIST
AND IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR YOU
TO MISINTERPRET IT AS SUCH.
- OKAY, IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'RE ABOUT TO SING
THE MOST RACIST SONG
SO FAR.
- I'M NOT.
♪ HIDEY-LIDEY-LIDEY-LEE ♪
♪ GET ME A ROPE
AND FIND ME A TREE ♪
- OKAY, I'M OUT.
- COME ON, MAN. HEY!
SHOOT.
I'M OVER HERE TRYING
TO SING ABOUT A TIRE SWING.
GONNA WRITE OFF
AN ENTIRE GENRE OF MUSIC.
[playing guitar]
♪ THE BANJOS ARE STRUMMING,
AND THE DRUMS ARE A-BANGIN' ♪
♪ LET'S GET THE BOYS TOGETHER
AND HAVE OURSELVES A-HANGIN' ♪
OH, DAMN.
NOW I SEE IT.